hi tech fan Sam grub are here at
Samsung's unpacked event in New York and
this is the galaxy note for the note 4
is Samsung's flagship tablet like ship
phablet try saying that five times fast
and that's in part because it has this
huge display let me give you a sense
first of all just how big this phone is
this is the note for this is an iphone
5s the note 4 has been shopping a lot at
Rochester big and tall that 5.7 inch
display is a super amoled quad HD
display and let me show you what that
means pictures are incredibly sharp and
incredibly bright now on the rear of the
phone is a 16 megapixel camera with 8x
digital zoom there's also the s-pen
stylus which people can use if they like
that sort of thing I've never quite
understood it I always thought my finger
was good enough in addition perhaps the
most interesting feature about this
phone is its battery life you can charge
this phone to fifty percent in 30
minutes now a lot of people been talking
about larger phones lately there's been
some rumors that Apple might come out
with a larger device but Samsung's
actually been doing this for quite some
time and when they first started there
are a lot of people who are skeptical
but the market has responded and
responded wildly people like a big phone
and with this model samsung is hoping to
sustain that lead